et pour en parler nous sommes avec notre
éditorialiste politique alexis poulain
lexique poulain bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin en direct alors le
télétravail obligatoires dont les
entreprises pour tous ceux qui le
peuvent à partir d'aujourd'hui de
nouvelles mesures également applicable
dès ce lundi pour lutter contre l
épidémie jean castex qui va se réunir
avec dix ministres dans la journée pour
faire le point sur le vario mikron le
mois de janvier s'annonce périlleux pour
le gouvernement
oui peyrieu ça dépend un peu de la
viralité et d'être dangerosité de ce
variant mikron dont on a l'impression
que ce n'est pas vraiment le cas donc on
espère que cette vague comme le dit
olivier vers en une du jdd sera la
dernière peut-être mais on a quand même
encore une fois un mise en scène deux du
gouvernement des amateurs fier avec deux
ministres à olivier ferrand et jean
castex qui étale les mesures dans deux
journaux réservé aux abonnés avant
qu'elles soient publiées sur les sites
des ministères bien sûr jean castex
ministe pardon excusez moi je me sens
michel blanc caire ministre de
l'éducation qui lui décide de rendre
hommage aux élèves un qui attendent la
veille de la rentrée pour faire leurs
devoirs et qui a changé les protocoles
et les a annoncées la veille pour des
centaines de milliers de professeurs et
de famille avec un changement sur l'
isolement sur les tests pour éviter de
fermer des classes encore une fois un
gouvernement qui n'a rien prévu avec des
masques ffp2 qui sont censés être mieux
pour protéger face à ce mario mikron est
bien les enseignants n'en seront pas
dotés ils sont réservés pour les
soignants sans doute encore une pénurie
de masques puisque là où il y avait des
producteurs de masques français ils ont
mis la clé sous la porte encore une fois
le gouvernement fait semblant de lutter
contre cette pandémie il n'ya rien
préparé il n'a rien mis en place que ce
soit les purificateurs d'air également
le ministère de l'éducation n'a rien
fait il incite les collectivités a
demandé de l'argent pour pouvoir les
installer mais il n'y a aucune
coordination au niveau de l'état si ce
n'est beaucoup de communication une
embolie communicationnel qui fait qu'on
ne comprend plus du tout ces mesures
c'est beaucoup trop compliquée entre les
vacciner les non vaccinés on ne sait
plus qui est vacciné entre les doses et
ce qu'ils doivent rester chez eux ce
qu'ils peuvent sortir le télétravail on
est là dans un flou total alors que tout
ça aurait pu être préparée depuis le
mois de décembre avec jean castex qui va
réunir ses ministres encore une fois
pour faire de la communication et pas de
la gestion de crise puisque les masques
banques on est en 2020 deux ans de
pandémie et ce gouvernement n'a rien
appris et continue de gérer de manière
totalement amateur cette crise sanitaire
ou alors c'est que c'est le cri
sanitaire est bien le gouvernement ne la
prend pas vraiment au sérieux même si
elle a déjà fait pourtant plus de 120
mille morts donc c'est inquiétant et
c'est à la fois aussi surprenant de voir
ce gouvernement qui y patauge comme il y
a deux ans avec des mesures alors on va
nous dire que c'est à cause de ce mal
cran de ce variant au micro je crois
qu'il ya autre chose il ya vraiment une
volonté d'impréparation une volonté
aussi de perdre des français dans des
mesures qui sont devenus aujourd'hui
illisible on l'a vu se nourrir dans les
transports même la sncf a assoupli
finalement ce ne sont pas vraiment des
lois et puis on va bien sûr aujourd'hui
à l'assemblée parler de ce pass
vaccinale qui reste est en droit et en
morale totalement inacceptable et
justement lors de ses voeux vendredi
soir emmanuel macron a parlé longuement
de vaccination mettant encore davantage
la pression sur les non vaccinés
pourquoi le gouvernement ne passe pas la
vaccination obligatoire pour tous sans
détour tout simplement parce qu'il ne
peut pas le faire
à la fois parce qu'il serait responsable
donc c'est une vaccination obligatoire
dé facto un qui est donnée par extorsion
vaccinale avec ce fameux pass vaccinale
qui pousse à la troisième dose ou à la
première dose pour ceux qui n'ont pas
encore tout simplement pour ne pas être
responsable non seulement nous avons un
gouvernement d'amateurs fier mais
d'irresponsables qui organisent leur
irresponsabilité à tel point que agnès
buzyn ancien ministre de la santé un qui
est mise en examen pour mise en danger
de la vie d'autrui et bien a reçu une
décoration de la légion d'honneur seul
dans la prévention du 1er janvier donc
on voit bien qu'il ya une sorte de du
bri d'odile au delà des lois donc on
pousse finalement les français en leur
tordant le bras à cette vaccination sans
en assumer la responsabilité
c'est le cas par exemple en australie ou
un fonds a été mis en place par l'état
qui va rembourser les victimes de cette
vaccination parce qu'il y a des effets
secondaires même si beaucoup trop de
médias on parle trop peu il ya des des
morts et les effets secondaires de ces
élections donc l'état devrait rembourser
si c'était le cas on voit bien que tout
ça est mis en place pour éviter la
responsabilité donc on pousse les gens
et puis pire encore le gouvernement
s'entête dans cette politique indigne du
bouc émissaire chaque épidémie a eu son
bouc émissaire au siècle dernier c'était
une fois les riches qui voulait se
débarrasser des pauvres une fois les
juifs qui propageaient l'économie et
bien cette fois ci ce sont les non
vaccinés qui sont devenus les boucs
émissaires de cette épidémie eux qui
finalement n'ont qu'à un tort c'est
d'aller davantage l'hôpital que les
vacciner mais les vaccinés propage
l'épidémie autant quasiment que les non
vaccinés donc on est là dans une
politique de la division une politique
qui montre du doigt une catégorie de la
population qui n'a rien fait et c'est
assez terrible de voir comment la
république est ainsi maltraité nous
sommes à quelques mois des élections
présidentielles est ce que la question
sanitaire peut occulter tous les autres
thèmes de la campagne électorale
c'est hélas le cas dès à présent on voit
bien que le champ politique c'est
totalement réduits autour de cette
question sanitaire à la fois parce qu'il
est impossible d'en critiquer la réponse
par le gouvernement sous couvert de
passer pour un dangereux criminel ou un
complotiste parce qu'il est difficile de
même critiqué ce pass vaccinale alors
même encore une fois qu'il faut le
redire beaucoup de juristes le dise que
en droit il est inacceptable et
moralement inacceptable est
sanitairement peu efficient donc on voit
bien que tous les autres sujets pour le
moment sont mis de côté même si les les
autres candidats continuent de faire
campagne puisque emmanuel macron à le
président candidat non déclaré qui va
utiliser la présidence
européenne pour se mettre en scène
davantage au niveau international sans
doute pour ce qui est des autres sujets
pouvoir d'achat immigration on en a un
peu parlé lors de la candidature d'eric
zemmour et puis le reste en fait d'eux
des différentes administrations
éducation santé évidemment parce que les
soignants sont les grands oubliés encore
une fois de cette crise sanitaire on
voit bien que ces sujets là sont
balayées mis de côté sur la table avec
lors de l'allocution du président macron
une cavalcade 1 pour m différentes
mesures les unes à côté des autres qui
sont des mesurettes finalement de ce
quinquennat le bilan est bien maigre il
ne reste rien à l'esprit donc on voit
que c'est aussi un choix qui permet de
poser le président et son gouvernement
au centre de l'attention ce sont eux qui
nous enferment qui nous masque qui nous
des masses qui oblige les enfants à se
masquer puis à se démasquer qui peut
devenir le sauveur par une pirouette de
communication à partir du mois de mars
mais tous les autres sujets sont comme
cryogénisé commis en attente on ne parle
plus encore une fois que du virus ça
fait deux ans c'est beaucoup trop long
pour tous les français alexis poulain
éditorialiste politique merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions